un bon soir le journal de tv soixante
dix huit pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez voici les titres de ce
jeudi 14 janvier un plan pour sauver
renault le groupe automobile implanté
notamment à guyancourt et
flins-sur-seine présenté ce matin
renault lution sa stratégie de relance
huit mois après avoir déclenché un plan
d'économies de 2 milliards d'euros sur
trois ans à retenir une production à la
baisse mais fait de véhicule de
meilleure qualité s'orientant davantage
vers l'hybride et l'électrique et les
réactions dans ce journal avec les
syndicats de la marque au losange
l'automobile qui est en crise après une
année 2010 cauchemardesque moins 25% de
vente c'est un secteur pourtant porteur
dans les yvelines avec plus de 30000
emplois salariés des sites de production
historique des centres de recherche et
de développement et des sièges sociaux
sont présents sur le territoire focus et
puis reportage dans cette édition à
triel-sur-seine la municipalité a mis en
circulation une navette électrique trois
circuits sont déployés pour permettre
aux habitants de se déplacer
gratuitement dans la ville et dans un
instant le premier ministre jean castex
va prendre la parole pour faire un point
d'étape sur la crise sanitaire du coc
vie de 19 nous reviendrons sur les
principales annonces à retenir dans ce
journal c'est à la fin de cette édition
cette disparition d'abord pour débuter
ce journal celle de marielle de sarnez
et qui est décédé hier à l'âge de 69 ans
elle se battait depuis plusieurs mois
contre une leucémie plus proche
conseillère de françois bayrou est la
député modem de paris était également
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée nationale
à la vérité pendant une courte période
ministre des affaires européennes de mai
à juin 2010 est l'europe l'une de ses
convictions marielle de sarnez avait été
eurodéputés de 1999 à 2010 est dans la
circonscription ile de france sur les
images que vous venez de voir c'était à
versailles elle était venue en 2015
défendre la candidature du modem aux
élections régionales écoutez les
réactions de deux de ses collègues
député des yvelines également membre du
modem jean noël barrot et bruno myle
yens interrogé ce matin par mélanie
poker petit personnel c'est évidemment
avec une infinie tristesse que j'ai
appris ça
nouvelle et laissent derrière elles
évidemment un véritable monde elle a été
l'une des artisanes du sens qu'en france
la destination ou fait un petit
personnel je me disais depuis deux ans
avec elle
quasi quotidiennement c'est donc un gros
chagrin et je crois que ce type la
tamise du si nous avons aussi bien
grandi c'est parce qu'elle était là pour
nous pousser pour aller chercher au fond
de nous tout ce qu'on avait dans nos
tripes et puis quand on fait glisser un
petit peu elle était là aussi pour nous
réconforter d'il ya trois axes 1 qui
peuvent même 4 qui peuvent définir
marielle il ya l'humanisme il ya cette
militante infatigable du centrisme ne
supportait pas c'est combat droite
gauche pour elle une idée est bonne
parce qu'elle est bonne parce qu'elle
est de droite ou de gauche donc elle
s'est battue pour le centrisme toute sa
vie et puis il ya son combat pour
l'europe et pour les femmes qui étaient
absolument extraordinaire c'est une
européiste convaincue elle a toujours
poussé à plus d'intégration au niveau
européen ça va peut-être se faire et
malheureusement elle lira pas les
résultats de ces combats mais on les
poursuivra en sa mémoire de toute façon
marielle de sarnez était bien connu des
élus locaux y vino et notamment de jean
baptiste à monique maire de villepreux
également depuis peu président du modem
des yvelines on les écoute ils étaient
tous au micro de michael et demi d'euros
évidemment je la connaissais
personnellement comme c'est le cas de
nombreux élus et des adhérents du
mouvement démocrate des yvelines
notre chagrin et profond j'ai une pensée
pour ses proches pour sa famille pour
son fils augustin et évidemment pour
françois bayrou parce que marielle de
sarnez était son bras droit
c'est la vice présidente de notre
mouvement et
mais sera en tout cas un grand vide au
sein du mouvement démocrate voilà pour
ces réactions suite à la disparition de
marielle de sarnez la centriste c'était
un tiers mercredi à l'âge de 69 ans
l'actualité du jour c'est ce plan
renault lution le nom de cette nouvelle
la stratégie du groupe renault son
directeur général lucas demeo a présenté
ce programme ce matin et dans les
grandes lignes l'entreprise souhaite
produire moins de véhicules mais créer
plus de valeur pour cela les autres
marques du groupe vont se distinguer sur
le marché de par leur identité et leur
positionnement
principal enseignement avec des
implications pour le territoire des
yvelines le programme software
république une stratégie tournée vers
l'innovation avec deux grands groupes
tournés autour de la gestion des data de
la cyber sécurité de l'internet des
objets il sera implanté au technocentre
renault de guyancourt en clair mettre
des domaines innovants du numérique
destiné aux services de l'automobile
notamment avec le développement du
véhicule autonome le groupe renault
collabora entre autres avec orange
dassault systèmes ou encore
stmicroelectronics
on écoute les détails de l'ucad et méo
il faut imaginer que je la sauveteuse
république
marc est un laboratoire à ciel ouvert
géant où l'on peut faire des expériences
sur des véhicules autonomes et connectés
dans un environnement contrôlé en temps
réel
ce faisant nous allons ouvrir 100 mille
mètres carrés dans nos installations à
nos partenaires et là les logiciels et
aussi d'autres innovations de rupture
seront développées et testées of nous
allons offrir une proximité avec nos
infrastructures d'ingénierie avec nos
compétences techniques lund et nous
allons aussi inclure notre renault
software factory ou blanc ce labo venir
où nous allons localiser 1000 ingénieurs
et des tas scientist qui sont les
meilleurs que l'on puisse trouver sur le
marché du côté de l'usiné historique de
flins-sur-seine l'autre site du groupe
dans le département renault souhaite la
transformer en établissement spécialisé
dans l'économie circulaire avec des
services dédiés aux véhicules
électriques et à l'énergie
actuellement le site produit des
véhicules renault zoé nissan micra
production qui
être a définitivement en 2024 l'objectif
est de devenir le leader dans ce secteur
on écoute de nouveaux lucas demeo elle
dit wifaq à la refactorisation nous
allons reconditionnés plus de 100000
véhicules d'occasion par an nous allons
reconvertir dans des véhicules
utilitaires diesel est passé violent et
au biogaz et aux 100 % électrique bilité
de nous allons mettre à niveau les
véhicules des plateformes de mobilité
avec de nouvelles batteries nous allons
récupérer les batteries usagées nous
allons le retrouver une deuxième vie
c'est pour cela que l'on dit que les
véhicules renault vont en fait duré plus
longtemps et pour réagir à ces annonces
du groupe renault qui concerne vous
l'avez compris des sites implantés dans
les yvelines deux invités avec moi par
visioconférence tout d'abord yacine aldi
dit bonsoir bonsoir élu cfdt du comité
social économique de renault flins est
lié également avec nous jean-françois
pibouleau bonsoir manche sera délégué
syndical central cgt du groupe renault
vous êtes également un salarié sur le
site du technocentre renault à
guyancourt alors déjà j'aimerais vous
entendre
globalement sur ces annonces avant de
rentrer dans le détail de vos sites
respectifs on connaissait la couleur est
depuis mai dernier à savoir ce plan
d'économies de 2 milliards d'euros sur
trois ans qui a été voulu par la
direction là c'est une nouvelle
stratégie en tout cas c'est ce qui est
annoncé par la direction avec de
nouvelles orientations votre avis déjà
général sur sur les annonces que l'on a
pu entendre ce matin va commencer avec
yacine aldi dit écoutez les réactions se
font à ce faux nombreuses dans un
premier temps en tout cas en terme en
terme général moi je parlais en terme
général le projet en lui-même il est
ambitieux il ya beaucoup de choses qui
seront là beaucoup de choses nouvelles
et beaucoup de choses que les salariés
n'ont pas reconnu qu'ils vont connaître
dans les années à venir
mais l'autre côté en faite le
le point en fait négatif c'est que
comment comment on va s'y prendre
carrément donné qu'on reste dans l'image
pour renault fabrique que des véhicules
type à la base c'était renault fabrique
des voitures
demain ce qu'on voit quand même
fabriquer des voitures on va pas vers
l'autre autre chose donc à un moment
donné j'ai franchement aujourd'hui à
écouter à écouter le directeur général
lui il est vraiment sûr de lui donc un
moment donné est ce qu'on doit faire à
se rendre à l'écouter on doit lui faire
confiance aveuglément et aller dans ce
sens pas on doit vraiment voilà un
moment donné tir sera fait se défendre
mais je pense que il va aider
il a des idées en tête il nous parle de
ses projets de de volkswagen de ses
atouts il était et c'est que qu'il avait
fait en gros que la même mener sa
stratégie centrale et j'ai été payante
etc
sauf qu'aujourd'hui nous on a en france
voilà nous renault prenait il ya un
historique et pour nous on a des voix là
nous on a des inquiétudes de grosses
inquiétudes notamment sur le site de
flins on a compris des annonces
ambitieuse mais de la réserve tout de
même jean françois petit boulot qu'est
ce que vous en avez pensé
tout d'abord c'est une annonce
qui à but purement financiers c'est à
dire que c'était faire un geste
vis-à-vis des marchés financiers et le
contenu du projet n'est pas
véritablement destiné aux hauts salariés
à l'activité industrielle s'est c'est
véritablement une stratégie une macro
stratégie du groupe
voilà il ya des choses intéressantes qui
sont proposés nous la cgt depuis deux
ans nous avons mis en débat une
stratégie industrielle du groupe
on retrouve aujourd'hui des des réponses
à certaines de nos de nos demandes mais
effectivement ce qu'il faut c'est voir
la déclinaison industriels et et dans
les études de ce qui a été proposé
aujourd'hui car l'avenir c'est tout de
même les emplois monsieur di meo dit
qu'il veut ramener de la valeur à ces
véhicules ils souhaitent pas être jugé
sur ses aînés volume nous on le jugera
comme on a pu lui dire à plusieurs
reprises sur les effectifs et sur le
développement industriel et le
développement des études sur le
territoire mais également dans tous les
sites à travers le monde
la première chose que nous demandions
dans cet entretien son unité sur
laquelle choisir on se demande sur le
site du technocentre de guyancourt
puisque le temps file dans cet entretien
il on le sait on l'a appris il y aura le
déploiement sur place du software
république c'est à dire une innovation
en collaboration avec les grands groupes
sur place sur la place du numérique un
le numérique dans le véhicule aller
davantage vers une autonomie plus
connectés plus autonome aussi est-ce que
vous avez des détails sur ce quoi ce à
quoi pourrait ressembler la mise en
oeuvre de cette software république au
technocentre
bah écoutez
on n'a pas plus de détails que cela on
sait qu'il ya des idées des mètres
carrés qui seront destinés à ce
laboratoire on va dire c'est ce centre
de tout les gens pourront travailler
ensemble la cgt défend des partenariats
mutuellement avantageux pour l'ensemble
des sociétés
la seule inquiétude que l'on a c'est que
nous effectivement on a déjà des
services ont été menées sans qui
s'occupe du sauveur qui est on a
également une filiale
enfin une filiale qui s'occupe de ça la
renault sauveur lab qui est installé à
il ya une partie à toulouse et notre
parti à excusez moi du côté de cannes
est donc le on veut savoir comment les
gens vont travailler ensemble pour que
ça soit mutuellement avantageux pour
l'ensemble des des des entreprises qui
vont s'y investir
il ya à tossiat orange il ya des
sociétés qu'on connaît c'est à ça peut
être intéressant
il faut que ça soit mutuellement
avantageuse et que derrière ça se
traduise également dans de la
fabrication industrielle sur le
territoire français et sur les autres
territoires pour l'ensemble de nos
marques
on aura l'occasion de vous entendre
peut-être lors d'une autre édition
notamment sur le centre technique de
villiers saint frédéric ce que voilà
vous êtes délégué cgt central
par contre on va terminer cet entretien
ce qu'on aimerait aussi entendre yassine
al zaïdi sur le site de flins sur seine
on sait yacine aldi dit que l'arrêt de
la production automobile se fera sur
place a été confirmé la date butoir
c'est 2024 avec un site qui sera
transformé en un établissement
spécialisé dans l'économie circulaire
automne automobile votre regard sur ce
projet pour le site de flins est ce que
vous savez si parmi les quatre mille 600
suppressions de postes dont on parle en
français ce que le site de flins est
aujourd'hui concerné également à écouter
nos sur le projet sur sur flins
évidemment évidemment qu'il ya des ratés
l'effectif qui sera qui sera déduit ça
on en est pratiquement sûr
malgré que la direction elle veut nous
induire en erreur en disant qu' il y
aura du travail pour tout le monde mais
ça nous on la croit pas une seconde
maintenant sur les activités en
elle-même le nombre d'activités qui vont
atterrir sur le sur l'usiné de flins le
la cfdt on avait émis déjà des réserves
on l'avait dit qu'on était pour en fait
les activités nouvelles ça créerait de
l'emploi ça va générer chose dans
l'usiné par contre à une condition c'est
que voilà que la direction maintient
l'activité principale inquiets
l'assemblage du véhicule
aujourd'hui des usines de flins c'est
une usine qui fabrique des véhicules
donc ça a abandonné nous la cfdt c'est
no 3 en fait c'était notre ligne rouge
et si vous voulez c'est par hasard que
ce que la zoé aujourd'hui est le premier
véhicule électrique en europe c'est pas
un hasard si on fait la nissan
aujourd'hui à plein c'est pas un hasard
si en 2010 est porté
il y avait en fait français a été portée
comme l' usine du futur c'est pas un
hasard c'est qu'en juillet 2010 huit
entreprises annoncé un milliard
d'investissements pour le véhicule
électrique et la modernisation de doué
et de la primauté pour flins a fabriqué
la future remplaçante de la zone
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
passaient drc à bord avant 2020 et
aujourd'hui voilà on nous annonce que
finalement en gros baffe là on va te
finir une usine voilà en route de
bricolage ça vraiment retrait des
salariés de l'usiné
c'est une forme de provocation c'est il
ya eu un mouvement de grève au mois de
juin ont beaucoup de ça ou beaucoup de
salariés ont manifesté leur
mécontentement
quand ils ont entendu des annonces ce
n'est contentement il a il est toujours
présent aujourd'hui l usine de flins
parce qu'on n'a pas en fait nous a
toujours pas rassuré aujourd'hui on a eu
la visite de norohna la visite du
directeur général deux fois de suite
et aujourd'hui le djia est un général
lui reste sur postaux de cette position
quand sur ses positions il est confiant
il nous dit que les des projets qui vont
arriver vaut mettre fin voilà décoller
et ses messages que nous allons donner
ça nous pose problème c'est
peur du site en fait l'histoire du site
l'effectif parce que pour nous
l'effectif sera pas maintenu aujourd'hui
on et 3600 donc demain on sait pas
combien on sera
il ya beaucoup de questions il ya une
autre question aujourd'hui la direction
a du mal à nous répondre et nous la cfdt
voilà nous notre bail il est maintenu on
a même fait un projet on a en a fait un
projet de plusieurs pages qu'on a remis
au directeur général avec un courrier
comme quoi voilà nous on propose c'est
ça puisqu'on a aussi fait des
propositions on usine de flins tout en
maintenant l'activité principale est à
ce jour on n'a pas eu de réponses on n'a
pas eu de réponse à ce projet
ce projet où on a passé plusieurs mois à
le à le construire avec des spécialistes
avec on a perdu du temps de l'argent
c'est c'était vraiment un projet de
grande envergure mais aujourd'hui elle
dit je suis désolée de vous couper on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien on
revient à ce que vous faisiez finalement
au début avec de nouvelles annonces ça
vous étiez plutôt satisfait en tout cas
sur les nouvelles annonces mais toujours
des réserves sur le fait qu on aille
moins vers de pros de la production
automobile qui est à la base des sens
même de renault ce que vous aviez dit au
début de cet entretien merci en tout cas
à vous de yassine al didier et merci à
jean françois pibouleau delà de la cgt
d'avoir été avec nous vous avez
finalement assez peu de temps de parole
mais on souhaitait aussi avoir la voix
de des deux syndicats cfdt cgt dans
cette journée d'annonce du groupe
renault merci d'abord été avec nous a
reçus et des annonces de renault dans un
contexte très difficile un plus
généralement pour le monde de
l'automobile la crise sanitaire c'est
mieux vous le savez en crise économique
et le secteur automobile n est pas sans
reste les précisions dans ce sujet de
bixente maria santisteva 2020 une année
compliquée pour le marché automobile en
france les ventes de voitures pour
particuliers en chuté de 25 5% en un an
c'est la plus grosse baisse recensés sur
les 40 dernières années
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée la
crise financière de 2008 n'avait
engendré qu'une baisse de 13 88% dans ce
secteur
le groupe renault comme le groupe psa
enregistre une chute de 25,1 et 24 9%
une crise qui ne touche donc pas un
producteur français plus qu'un autre
parmi les groupes étrangers qui vendent
en france c'est le groupe fiat chrysler
qui regroupe notamment alfa romeo et
jeep et fiat qui a le plus souffert
plus de 40 % de pertes pour rappel une
fusion a été signé entre le groupe italo
américain et psa le 4 janvier dernier
donnant le nom de stèles en tice le
groupe qui devait ainsi prendre la
quatrième place mondiale au classement
des constructeurs de l'automobile se
retrouvera après le christ probablement
à la 6e position au final seuls les
entités hyundai et all toyota lexus en
sorte avec un peu moins de 15% de baisse
sur le chiffre d'affaires du marché
français si l'on devait retenir autre
chose de cette année c'est bien
l'augmentation significative des ventes
de voitures hybrides et électriques
face à la crise l'état a procédé à
l'augmentation du bonus écologique pour
booster les ventes
ce sont environ 149 mille
immatriculations qui ont été créés pour
des voitures de ce type contre seulement
60 milles en 2019
une croissance qui devrait se poursuivre
cette année également puisque le bonus
écologique pour l'achat de voitures en
2021 pour et à lui jusqu'à 7000 euros
plus globalement en 2021 l'observatoire
cetelem prévoit une croissance du marché
de l'automobile de 19% en france les
intentions des français d'acheter une
voiture n'aurait pas changé malgré la
crise qui nous aura seulement contraints
à pousser leurs projets d'acquisition
d'un véhicule à plus tard
c'est une crise qui se ressent d'autant
plus dans les yvelines un département
historiquement liées à l'automobile avec
des sites de production des sièges
sociaux et des centres de recherche et
développement sur le territoire 15% des
effectifs salariés du secteur
travaillent dans le département yves les
noix une place prépondérante dont nous
parle une nouvelle fois bixente mayence
insisté ban avec 34 1514 emploi les
yvelines sont classés numéro un français
en terme d'effectif salarié dans le
secteur de l'automobile
si le département est devenu un lieu
historique de production de véhicules en
ile de france c'est grâce au passage de
la seine en amont de paris ainsi que sa
proximité avec la capitale
les produits pouvant être transportés
plus facilement par bateau 20e siècle
quatre communes concentre aujourd'hui la
quasi totalité des salariés de la
filière le technocentre renault de
guyancourt et le principal pôle
yvelinois onze mille salariés
travaillent pour la recherche et le
développement des futures voitures de la
marque
c'est le plus grand centre de recherche
de france il permet à l'entreprise
d'éviter de nombreux coups en frais de
déplacement autres citronnelle usine
située à flins aubergenville et le 4e
employeur événement site historique de
la renault clio
il fabrique actuellement les renault zoé
ainsi que les nissan micra
il ne produira plus prochainement
d'automobiles parmi les autres pôles on
trouve deux centres psa l'un situé à
vélizy villacoublay destinées en partie
à conceptualiser le design des futurs
modèles
le second à poissy spécialisée dans la
motorisation des véhicules
ces deux espaces regroupe au total neuf
mille six cents salariés
les sièges de firmes étrangères se sont
également installés progressivement dans
le département en particulier à saint
quentin en yvelines
on retrouve ainsi les sièges mercedes
benz bmw france est nissan europe à
montigny le bretonneux ou encore fiat
france à trappes
en tout ce sont 350 établissements
rassemblés dans les yvelines soit 23% du
total en ile-de-france dans le reste de
l'actualité c'était une promesse de
campagne la nouvelle municipalité de
triel sur seine vient de dévoiler sa
nouvelle navette électrique trois
circuits sont prévus pour permettre aux
habitants de se rendre à des quartiers
vers le centre ville et cela de façon
écologique est gratuite
astrid bergère et pierre hugot reiber
favoriser les déplacements de proximité
c'est la raison pour laquelle une
navette électrique vient d'arriver à
triel sur seine jusqu'au 26 janvier le
service est en phase d'expérimentation
pour valider les choix faits en
concertation avec les habitants
avec cette concertation n'a pu définir
certains arrêts donc des arrêts qui sont
stratégiques au niveau de la ville après
on a établi un planning et donc minutes
et un chronométrage assez précis et
maintenant à pouvoir valider ce
chronométrage et aussi apporter
éventuellement des modifications c'est
le but d'une phase de test trois
circuits différents ont été choisis et
tous passent par le centre ville grâce à
la mobilité interne nous allons pouvoir
prendre les personnes lésées menons en
centre-ville et redynamiser le commerce
et donc développer l'attractivité du
centre-ville dans la navette il ya au
total 22 places 11 à 6 9 de boue et un
emplacement pmr
elle a coûté un peu plus de 250000 euros
mais déjà subventionné à hauteur de 30%
et pour les usagers elle sera gratuite
la modernité des moyens de transport
aujourd'hui c'est aussi d'offrir quelque
chose
socialement qui sont intéressants et
pour toutes les catégories à deux
personnes qui résident à triel et
c'était aussi un enjeu capital pour
l'avenir de notre mobilité
ce nouveau mode de transport pourra
aussi être utilisé en dehors de ces
horaires habituels lors d'événements
organisés par la ville
nous allons à partir de la rentrée de
septembre 2021 offrir la possibilité aux
triellois de pouvoir lorsque le la crise
sanitaire le permettra bien entendu pour
l'événementiel pouvoir se déplacer plus
facilement non un système de
géolocalisation a été mis en place les
triellois peuvent donc suivre la navette
en temps réel sur l'application en bus
et avant de refermer cette édition je
vous le disais au début de ce journal le
premier ministre jean castex s'exprimait
ce soir il est toujours en train de
s'exprimer à l'heure où je vous parle
18h24 vous le savez une situation qui
est à difficile en france liées aux
coronavirus avec plus de 19 mille
nouveaux cas du colis 19 ans 24 heures
qui ont été recensés hier mercredi 13
janvier ont ce cas du variant anglais du
coronavirus qui est en circulation qui
sont en circulation actuellement en ile
de france une quarantaine de cas
suspects de ce fait de par cette
situation qui est difficile en ile de
france et dans le reste de la france le
premier ministre a annoncé ce soir
18h24 c'est la principale annonce à
retenir l'étendue l'élargissement du
couvre-feu à 18h pour l'ensemble du
territoire je vous le rappelle que 25
départements français étaient déjà sous
cette mesure du couvre-feu à 18 heures
elle est donc étendu à l'ensemble du
territoire une mesure qui sera mise en
place sur l'ensemble du territoire dès
samedi à 16 janvier pour 15 jours au
moins les commerces devront fermer donc
à 18 heures et également du côté des
écoles pas de fermeture annoncée pour le
moment de la part du premier ministre
jean castex mais il a annoncé le premier
ministre un renforcement des tests dans
les écoles qui donc sera fait dans les
prochains jours voilà ce qu'on pouvait
retenir de cette principale annonce
élargissement à l'ensemble du territoire
français du couvre-feu à 18 heures cette
annonce et les autres seront des
loupé lors de l'émission sept huit
week-ends qui est au programme demain à
vendredi sur tv 78 voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]